nous devons lorsque cela peut sauver des
vies offrir la possibilité aux médecins
de déroger au secret médical
cette annonce faite ce matin par le
premier ministre nous avons décidé de la
montrer à trois personnes un médecin un
procureur et la directrice d'une
association de victimes
si la levée partielle du secret médical
divise ce médecin généraliste lui s'en
félicite risque aujourd'hui parfois
d'être complice bien involontaire du
compagnon ou du marais qui l'a battue je
crois qu'il faut quand même évolué
permettre cette levée exceptionnelle du
secret médical
quand on voit les chiffres 137 ma femme
décédée et combien battue je crois qu'il
faut il faut faire avancer la loi chaque
année 220 mille femmes sont victimes de
violences conjugales
pour ce procureur les témoignages des
médecins peuvent être décisifs
je pense que puisqu'il est utile et
qu'il a fait la démonstration de son
efficacité pour par exemple les mineurs
victimes
c'est un système qui pourrait en
fonction de la façon dont il est conçu
faire montrer l'efficacité pour éviter
des drames en matière de vue de
violences intrafamiliales
mais cette annonce du premier ministre
ne convainc pas tout le monde pour cette
directrice d'associations c'est la
méthode qui n'est pas bonne nous sommes
toujours partisan du fait que les femmes
fassent les démarches
voilà donc de les aider à les faire au
maximum de facilité les choses mais pas
de les faire à leur place parce que là
enfin il me semble que là il ya vraiment
une rupture de confiance
comment une femme va pouvoir justement
allé parler à son médecin de famille si
elle se dit mais en plus il va pouvoir
maintenant le signaler jamais elle va
lui parler
le gouvernement doit maintenant
rencontrer l'ordre des médecins pour
discuter des modalités de la levée du
secret médical